[Music]
in true love news lovers of a true
submitted by JK give any life thank you
she doesn't believe in it a Japanese
princess gives up her royal status to
marry a commoner
what a loser don't oh my god why could
it be why couldn't the commoner get come
on yeah eagle-eye disapprove no fish
farmers here what happened Julia tell me
the details really get bumped up like
during the British Royal Family maybe
four men Oh from what I was reading the
way that the Japanese world family runs
this is that when a daughter marries
she's actually like married off to
whoever that fella like she loses her
status oh that's so rude
how many time I have a question yes so
he doesn't even come up so besides the
fact where wife he's got a wife now you
ever come up I mean besides the fact
that she's commodity and she's used as a
political tie so what makes someone a
commoner and what makes someone like you
can marry them because you're royal
hmm that's my question true love duh no
no like right now I'm kidding like that
I did a blood line I thought that if
they could only marry other Royals is
investment in a breathing air [ __ ] I was
trying to read into this but I'm not
exactly sure how one becomes royal all I
know is that there's about five males in
this royal family that can take the
throne to me it's more of this the wife
gives birth to a son and then that will
carry on the bloodline but I don't know
how the wife would skin Larry didn't
because there must be multiple
princesses right and this one's not the
only princess I'm assuming there's a ton
of them yeah and this one's probably
never going to be Queen she's just one
of the princess yeah she's just one of
them yeah I guess I'm just wondering
like so will the CEO of Toyota be a
royal or the a commoner like you'll
never be one of us but I just made upon
millions of dollars billions of dollars
but you're still a [ __ ] peasant and
she'll still be a commoner
common a CEO he might be more of like an
uncommon
congra kinda like the uncommon er this
is not royalty that means if it goes
into the palace still gotta get out some
of the [ __ ] nice house suck my dick
Toyota CEO with that how would it feel
to be a royalty right of this country
but you're poorer than your citizens
does that ever hide what you're poor
poor oh I think it's some of your
citizens themselves and some of the so
like let's say the Queen of England
right she's not the richest person in
England yeah she's probably like Lola
it's just status why she's higher and
she got the wackiest a through kind of
old school if she had her hand
I'll respect her this is princess Tonka
Wakan maka maka Mako and this is her
husband-to-be he's studying to become a
water that's pretty common so this is a
huge deal because most people don't give
up the royalty status it's a huge deal
because the number of royal family
members is decreasing Oh so I don't want
trying to hold on to their royal status
yeah but in the name of love
they gain together well a lot of people
in Japan they're curious as to what will
happen to the royal family if the
numbers continue to decrease so like
that's the big I got to be honest be
gone like a dodo bird yeah I know I
wonder what is going to happen maybe
everybody needs someone ask a question I
don't expect you to know the answer to
this but um what is yeah anyone in the
room what is the point of the royal
family like I get it back in the day
because I know now the Prime Minister
they're the ones that do in Japan
they're the longest-living monarchy so
there are direct lineage from Japan's
first emperor in the ancient times stuff
with the unbroken lineage of hereditary
like from father to son father to son
all the way but then in England and all
these other monarchies there's been
broke enough times where they had to
look for like a relative far away to
kind of bring back that's why there's so
many air like claims to the throne and
so many challenges to the throne
whereas in Japan the Royal Family's
always been the royal family I think
she's asking though like what does the
royal family do I think it's a hair it's
a part of heritage in a part of more
food yeah because they're like a
national treasure yeah I know that you
know how we stayed or went around the
imperial palace when I was doing some
research about that stuff is just it's
more like a historical figure head and
more of like a relic in a national pride
and culture yeah living legend then it
they have no real power yeah they don't
have to like the Emperor's is like
barred from political saying or
activities just a ceremonial person so
it's almost like having a living history
person did they get any like final calls
on specific things that like affect
their country maybe that'd be [ __ ]
you're tight it's like they get final
cause on like soccer games or battle
okay looking at the tape and we don't
know if that was a foul Colin the
Emperor any children hmm goes to team
Tokyo what if were a BDC like the
Japanese Emperor came out and he was the
last judge Heaviside get a deal with
that dude I've seen this story before
wasn't it Aladdin it was Eliza Saul this
guy's got a gears grind a freakin lamp
you paid attention so I'm saying seen it
before that Japanese tree rat is still
pretty good because he's a mole here
that's true okay homeless aren't you
dead guys with Schwartz so then here's
also another picture and stuffy he looks
the exact holiness and all I should
assume that outfit this is what I can
have it in but apparently looks hella
royal go with this weekend crown
I want a crown dude oh then is looking
at that photo I don't think that dudes
on our level
nah I don't even think that full knows
the difference between like a salad fork
and a regular fork here's my question is
like how did she even get access to her
you could have really powerful parents
you know what I mean like he could be
roaring in money or she or Julia
you'll clarify I went to college
together that's how they met and they
were dating since college cuz I just
assumed like royalty just has private
tutors and they have royalty school yeah
and they're trained to become like
royalty
they're trained to be on what they
already are exactly props to that I
don't know if they work right so like
imagine if your princess or Prince but
you're not one of the ones that's going
to step up to the plate to be the
Emperor or Empress or whatever right
you're literally just on welfare you're
a rich person on welfare and you can't
do [ __ ] you can't be yourself because
you have the image to uphold
but you're also not important enough to
make any calls you're just existing what
a [ __ ] sorry life I actually would be
like her and say [ __ ] being Prince I
don't care yes allure they're actually
on both twenty-five and they're engaged
together okay you're the oldest looking
agents I've ever seen really you look
older than 25 you look they're 25 they
look like they're [ __ ] sorry yeah but
this is also the resting like image of
what they will be for the next like 20
and a Chance like you're already just at
where you're at in the next twenty yeah
that's true
she's going to take a nosedive that like
50-something and it's going to go crazy
but until then she's gonna look exactly
like this - the crown of course because
of the marriage that I'm not sure but
I'm assuming that once she becomes a
commoner she loses her princess s it's
really she would be able to work oh I
don't know if I could stop having people
call me Prince Joseph or King Joseph or
some [ __ ] you know you're so used to it
all of a sudden I'm just Joe you've been
just Joe no if I if I was born into
royalty Joseph like that's how everybody
addresses me Prince Joseph and then
after a while it's just [ __ ] channel
just average Joe yeah because if people
don't wipe in your ass like your whole
life now you have to figure out a wipe
your own ass that's rough I just be in
the [ __ ] stalls at the University help
I need someone to do this to me that's
what I used to do when I was a kid my
cigar my grandpa's do at mass and even
though I knew how already you're so lazy
felt good
no I know you're talking about I was
just angry with my feet wow it's so
nurturing with someone else likes your
ass yeah and you just do it for like
this it's a short amount time to get to
three years of that goes on but he said
he already knew how to wife that's
insane see three years the day goes on
knowing but slacking yeah it's comfort
its and they do a thorough job too
because I know when I've I've I did I
always had an itchy butt it's a baby
weapon to ask for like 60 years by a
point like a good I remember playing on
a playground and I'm [ __ ] like I'm
like a dog like rubbing my butt on a
sand box making it more accessible man
on the sand so the way that news outlets
are describing the ISTE on say they're
saying like yeah you know he's a guy
that can ski you can play the violin you
can cook he was once known as the print
of the sea because he was like the sage
royalties to promote towards them on the
beaches of Shonen kanagawa prefecture I
love how they [ __ ] fluff his resume
at parties he's a world-class gear she
promoted so many freakin events at this
yeah
his life at the bailout challenge yeah I
did príncipe be flash tour guide is now
again like when I said earlier like a
lot of people are speculating like what
will happen to the royal family because
now there's only about five nails left
and the current Emperor wants to step
down because he's tired yeah like that
he won't be able to uphold his duties I
can't go to bed whatever it is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] calls and a backpack ah
you think what happened is it's not
tired I don't want to do this anymore
maybe have fun again
yeah I was only myself in the guys shoes
I'm a mass gotta be really stressful
because imagine she tries to give you a
[ __ ] right you know like [ __ ] she
is a royal princess
I don't know if I could stay in the mood
for that long because if she tries to
suck my dick I try to eat her out
because I'm due back out serve you is
just that's how it should be anyway you
know but it's like but it's not you
Fletcher so undeserving you know what I
mean if I step on my back I am a
commoner please step off my head [ __ ] on
my face but you just want like fetishes
now knowledge it's like can you it's
like what you're hiding what are you
doing to those royal lips while they're
around my wee-wee that's it that's what
I mean it's just what it's too much
stress but if she denounced her
princessness then maybe how my dear you
got a little comment or take that then
they're no longer way to live ok ok get
ok guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding News and if you guys
want to share a story there's a link
down in the description box below where
you can submit your story if you guys
want to watch more episodes click right
up here
[Music]
you
[Applause]